whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up officials
and formerly dog friend in New York City
for forbidding pooches anywhere food is
served in Michigan Governor Rick Snyder
kids have gotten so fat these days now
the government wants to start keeping
track of their weight snyder is
launching a statewide database to keep
anonymous tabs on kids body mass index
records but there can be only one nanny
of the month in this time it's san juan
capistrano city attorney Omar Sandoval a
san juan capistrano couple is under fire
and headed to court for hosting Bible
studies in their home the city says the
gatherings are illegal Californians
Chuck and Stephanie frown had posted
Bible studies since 1994 they say the
neighborhood supports them except for
one woman who recently complained
Sandoval says the fronds are violating a
code that forbids religious fraternal or
nonprofit organizations from meeting in
residential areas unless they get a
conditional use permit but doing so will
take money because it requires traffic
and environmental impact reports and
making their home accessible to
wheelchairs next stop the Superior Court
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minded your own business